pour parler de la grotte du secteur de
la santé nous sommes en direct avec
christophe prudhomme porte-parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france bonjour christophe prudhomme
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors nouveau rassemblement du personnel
hospitalier avec des manifestations
prévues à bordeaux et à paris devant
l'hôpital robert debré est ce que vous
vous attendez à une mobilisation plus
forte pour ce 3e jeudis colère écoutez
paris la cia robert debré le jeudi il ya
les mardis de la colère un peu partout
en france mardi et énormément d'hôpitaux
été mobilisés avec des salariés et la
population quand c'était possible devant
l'hôpital nous sommes tout à fait
satisfaits de la manière dont le
gouvernement traite nos revendications
on voit bien quand il s'agit de sauver
l'industrie automobile le gouvernement
annonce des chiffres pour l'instant ne
l'avons que les vagues promesses
aucun chiffre celle cantons demandent
des augmentations de salaires il faut
qu'ils aient une enveloppe en face
aujourd'hui aucune enveloppe budgétaire
aucune proposition concrète du
gouvernement alors que depuis un an nous
moment les choses très simples des
effectifs supplémentaires que nous avons
chiffré cent mille emplois à l'hôpital
deux cent mille en ehpad des
augmentations de salaire à hauteur de
300 euros nets pour tous
en attendant de pouvoir revoir
l'ensemble des gammes et le salaire mais
ça pourra passer en un mois et puis
dernière chose c'est que notre système
de santé est malade on l'a bien vu et ça
justifie nos arguments or le ministre le
premier ministre lui même dit que la loi
qui a été voté qui contestaient qui
s'appelle ma santé 2022 est une bonne
loi et que problème aujourd'hui n'est
pas de la modifier mais d'en accélérer
sa mise en oeuvre dans l'accélération de
sa mise en règle je le rappelle pour vos
auditeurs c'est la fermeture la
transformation de 300 hôpitaux de
proximité en ehpad plus de services
d'urgence plus de maternité depuis le
chirurgien des hôpitaux
c'est parce que nous voulons justement
le ségur de la santé a commencé lundi ce
qui laisse entrevoir de possibles
améliorations pour le personnel soignant
on entend bien votre colère est ce
qu'aujourd'hui le gouver
doit être concret à annoncer des
chiffres justement pour sauver l'hôpital
tout à fait ce que nous demandons savez
quand il ya des gens qui revendiquent et
vous voulez nier montré beaucoup de
manifestants dans la rue ils
revendiquent et ils ont posé des uns des
revendications qui sont très claires
donc quand on demande des posts je les
ai chiffre est quand on demande des
augmentations de salaires gelés et
chiffré le gouvernement doit nous faire
des propositions chiffrées ce qui me
fait pas jusqu'à présent donc la colère
monte
et vous savez pas que chez les soignants
tout le monde est très sceptique sur
l'organisation de ce fameux ségur de la
santé puis alors cerise sur le gâteau
nous proposer comme interlocutrice celle
que vous montrez en ce moment sur les
images d'un nicole notât avec sa
connotation politique
aujourd'hui dans un secteur où la cgt
est très largement majoritaire
pour nous ça frise la provocation est la
place de l'hôpital et celle de la santé
doivent elles être repensée ou bien
s'agit-il plutôt de les restaurer de
leur redonner des moyens et des
ambitions qui ont été abandonnés au fil
des décennies
pour nous il faut une réforme profonde
c'est à dire s'appuyer sur les deux
piliers la secteur qui ne peut pas être
un secteur marchand ca le service public
et une sécurité sociale intégral le
service public ça ici d'un système est
très coûteux aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'il est mixte public privé
on l'a vu avec les ehpad nous ce que
nous demandons c'est clair c'est la
suppression du secteur privé à but
lucratif dans la santé et le mandant
aussi la suppression de cette dualité de
prise en charge entre la sécurité
sociale et les assurances maladie
complémentaire c'est très coûteux
c'est complexe et ça n'a qu'une visée
s'y recueillaient des investisseurs qui
viennent sur le marché de la santé pour
s'accaparer la part qui est solvable la
population qui peut payer pour faire des
bénéfices mais les fils qui verseront à
leurs actionnaires
ce n'est pas sérieux ce n'est plus ce
que nous voulons aujourd'hui c'est le
service public et une sécurité sociale
intégral voilà donc c'est vraiment des
questions politiques fondamentales et ce
qui nous rend très optimiste aujourd'hui
c'est que nous avons un très fort
soutien à la population il faudra bien
que le gouvernement longtemps alors avec
la crise
terreau actuelle les rassemblements de
plus de dix personnes sont interdits la
semaine dernière plus de cinquante
personnes se sont fait verbalisé trois
ont été interpellés
est ce que vous craignez une répression
des manifestants vous savez la
répression la connais depuis très
longtemps vous avez vu que la france a
été montré du doigt par les organismes
internationaux
nous avons aujourd'hui un maintien de
l'ordre qui est très violent mes
collègues ophtalmologiste se sont quand
même on va alerter le président de la
république ce sont des professeurs de
médecine way qui ont interpellé
président de la république en disant
arrêtez d'utiliser les ailes bd voilà
donc que nous sommes face à un
gouvernement qui utilise la police ce
qui est une première en france un
pendant toute une période la police
française était louée pour sa capacité
justement à pouvoir gérer sans violence
les manifestations aujourd'hui on a des
ordres qui sont donnés à la police qui
sont d ordre qui entraîne des violences
entraînent des violences des blessés des
gardes à vue des privations de liberté
et ça c'est proprement scandaleux que le
gouvernement assure ali totalise la
police de cette manière la dernière
question très rapidement en tant que
médecin christophe prudhomme est ce
raisonnable de se rassembler aujourd'hui
alors que l'épidémie de corona virus
continue de circuler
oui oui c'est très raisonnable qui est
des réseaux la voyez dans une des villes
les plus denses du monde c'est la
querelle politicienne entre le
gouvernement et la ville de paris et de
maintenir le ferment la fermeture des
parcs et jardins
vous savez à l'extérieur le risque est
tout à fait limité le risque de
contamination
on essaye de faire au mieux si la police
ne la sait pas on pourrait garder nos
distances ce qui n'est pas le cas
donc voilà donc c'est pas nous
manifestants de lui montrer du doigt
parce que on le respectera pas les
mesures variable salée quand nous sommes
dans la rue nous soignants on est plus
en sécurité dans la rue que dans nos
services et en particulier on n'était
pas en sécurité quand le gouvernement
n'était pas en capacité de le fournir
des moyens de protection adaptées donc
arrêtons inverser les responsabilités
ceux qui nous ont mis en danger
c'est le gouvernement sont pas les
soignants aujourd'hui qui se rassemblent
qui mettent en danger la population bien
au contraire
christophe prudhomme merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin et porte
parole de l'association des mets
un urgentiste de france merci à vous